it's so cringe but i'm excited to watch
it with you
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome to very
funny
beth stelling hi beth hello thank you
for having me jp
this set was so long ago you recorded it
on a
flip camera i saw that that made me
laugh really hard
i tried to find the video and it's like
this no longer exists i'm like oh they
went out of business i guess
they ran out of space of everybody
capturing things from inside their
pocket
i think that i think it's so funny too
that going back just to see how i talk
to you in email i mean
i'm not that much different but it was
just funny like you know you always hope
that you're not like weird or say
something
you regret like if you go back through a
myspace message or something i think we
were definitely our emails back and
forth but a little bit more formal
than they are now yeah now i'm like
i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
why don't we just jump into this and
start watching all right
did you just hear my pen clicking over
and over again i'm like
i heard that you're like oh no we're
gonna watch this it's so
cringe but i'm excited to watch it with
you
you walk with purpose look at that i was
like just
head down making sure that i made it to
that x
that's right they do you do there is an
x right there for you to hit
you try to make it look cool but you're
just like it's funny that little things
you get wrapped up in
you know because the truth is like yes
you need to hit it but you don't need to
be like
right on it but nothing prepares you
from a little curtain i'm opening the
curtain for you
walking out finding your ex and then
performing not only just for the studio
audience
but knowing it's going out to a lot of
people and gonna live on youtube forever
gosh i'm wearing those shoes from
payless i have like two pairs still left
at my mom's house
and then those are like h m like capri
pants
that's like the equivalent of a male
wearing shorts i'm conan
i recently moved from illinois to
california
and i think that you would be
hard-pressed to find anybody here
tonight who's done something that brave
but i did and i just got some news from
my sister back home
she and her boyfriend accidentally
planned a baby
i'm cringing okay sorry it's making me
like giddy
in a bad way um
i just think it's too put on but i'm a
freaking 25 year old
you know what i mean like this is on
there forever you get to see me
like this and now i've changed
but it's up there forever
i just would do it more subtly you know
i don't like
i don't love like anything to put on you
know it's hard to avoid that
i think early on your career in a short
set like this i would do it differently
now
but i like what she did i love how i'm
trending like a different person
[Music]
i just went out and got an iud no sir
not a urinary tract infection
it's an intrauterine device in its birth
control lasts five years goes right in
your uterus it's the only time i'll say
uterus
said it again so i went in for my
consultation and the lady was like
bath um everything looks good uh
fun fact didn't know if you knew this
but your uterus
is actually tilted backwards
did you know that and i was like okay
so what you're telling me is even my
uterus is like
um
it's the first time i've seen a uterus
with personality
oh yeah yeah no that's true
i do like that joke like i said at the
beginning um
i've added a line since i don't like how
i made her voice
but this is now i'm just tearing myself
apart but um
when she says uh your uterus is tilted
backwards did you know that
and i added a line later that says uh
don't know how i could
you never stop tinkering with material
yeah i'm always tinkering we
literally had like set a date to take
the special just so you would stop
tinkering like that was the only way you
thank you that was stopped thank you
thank you so much
great job best selling very funny i was
like it's so cool he's walking over oh
my god
i felt like really excited that he was
walking over
and i don't know if it's because like i
don't know i didn't think
in my head i probably imagine bombing
and him sitting at the desk like
you know but it doesn't feel real i
guess
so when he came over and shook my hand i
was like i can't believe this is real
and even still i was like waiting for it
to air that night like maybe it's not
going to air
[Music]
if you see a good one it's almost like
you're going like
how far do i scroll down what can i get
before it says like
die i have pulled a few that i need to
share with you
oh no okay farflung floyd said
i'm going to assume that she's stoned
out of her mind it's just my like uh
like i said it's my that's just how it
comes out of me i get up there and i'm
like
i feel the pressure and i'm just like
stay calm
just do your thing eden shizzle said
reminds me of kate mckinnon had a child
with chelsea handler and melissa via
senor
interesting that's a wide range of
people i like it
over to my right you've got kevin nealon
watching which which did actually make
me feel good
it didn't make me feel nervous he's so
great and
i can't remember it was before or after
my set he introduced me to his parents
that were there
so that made me feel so good and they
were very kind
and kevin came over to me after conan
did and was like i love your style
you're so unique i wrote it down
somewhere so i can't remember the exact
quote
but i remember writing it down to
remember what kevin said to me
and then since i've got to do shows with
him at the lab factory and stuff and he
just emailed me yesterday about girl
daddy
and he said such kind things so like i
always have a special place for kevin
neal
in my heart and if you remember ben
stiller was there so it said
it's a beth spelling on my on my
dressing room and then next to it ben
stiller and i took a picture next to the
ben stiller one because
yes you know but um our initials
and so then i he we were shooting
something for whatever it is the
incredible life of walter mitty that
movie that he was in
where he's on conan in the movie so i
like
got to be there for that too which was
so cool and and ben walked by me and
said something nice too and i was like
my mind was blown
you know like oh my god i can't believe
i met men's killer
and kevin newman and jp buck
it's cool to think obviously eight years
later that
you guys and conan produced my hours
special and
um i've grown and changed so much you've
grown a lot since then but it was really
a lot of fun working on that
on that set with you and it's just great
that we're we're still doing this stuff
together
girl daddy on hbo man girl dad team coco
max
and i've been your male hostess today jp
buck